an eyewitness to the death of george
floyd has told the court in the u.s that
he could
see mr floyd quote slowly fading away
he was speaking on the first day of the
trial of derek shobin the white american
policeman accused of killing george
floyd
the court heard opening statements from
both the prosecution and the defense and
were shown
graphic footage of the incident our
correspondent sally lockwood reports now
from minneapolis
and just a warning that you may find
some of the images in her report
distressing
[Applause]
protests around the trial have been
peaceful but persistent
the first day ended with more calls for
justice for george floyd
but there's a hope here it will
represent a turning point in history
[Music]
before the jury former officer derek
shovin heard the prosecution's case
that george floyd would not have died
were it not
for his actions the video of him
restraining george floyd was their
exhibit a
27 cries that he couldn't breathe
prosecutors arguing derek chauvin had
nearly 10 minutes
to think about what he was doing you
will learn
that on may 25th of 2020
mr derek chavin betrayed this badge
when he used excessive and unreasonable
force
upon the body of mr george floyd
that he put his knees upon his neck and
his back
grinding and crushing him until
the very breath no ladies and gentlemen
until the very life
were squeezed out of him new footage
showed an initial struggle to pull
george floyd to the ground but what then
unfolded
so concerned a 911 dispatcher
she told the court she called the police
on the police involved
the defense though argued george floyd's
condition was down to drugs
and a heart condition you will learn
that derek shovin did exactly what he
had been trained to do
over the course of his 19-year career
the use of force is not attractive
but it is a necessary component of
policing
the floyd family lawyer ben crump
expected the defense to seek to
discredit george floyd's character
but he told me if he'd been a white
american
no one would say this is a hard case to
consider
it is because george floyd is an
african-american
and historically police officers are not
held accountable
for killing black people unjustifiably
in america
that's why everybody is saying this is
your opportunity america
to show us that you are the beacon
of hope and justice when it comes to
equality and justice fall
george floyd's death mobilized millions
in protest
worldwide but any hope this trial may be
a chance for change
is in the hands of 12 jurors sally
lockwood sky news minneapolis
and sky news will have full coverage of
the trial with continuous coverage of
the court proceedings streaming live on
our website and app
youtube and on a special pop-up channel
which you can find on sky channel
524 that's george floyd killing the
trial
full coverage on sky news